if you just I love you guys you're
awesome I'm glad you watch our videos
but don't come to our studio and please
for the love of God don't try and call
us because we don't have a phone here we
only have personal phone numbers
I'm just saying every day I get two or
three phone calls a day I pretty much
can't use my phone we have to literally
change my phone number because for some
reason my personal phone overs out there
it's not it's not court or digital
you're calling you're calling Sam and
I'm driving or I'm going grocery
shopping and spending time with my wife
we don't have a phone number we don't
have an address we don't exist anywhere
except for the Internet so that's where
you should contact us we've been having
people come by a lot lately unannounced
now I think it's really inspiring that
people would look at our work and go I
want to come by and meet those guys but
I don't think you guys are respecting
the fact that this is also a place of
work and a place where we expect privacy
think about it you like our videos and
you draw inspiration from them that's
wonderful
learn from them give us feedback in the
comments section even send us your
videos that's totally cool you may have
came from a long way and I'm sorry I
don't know what to say to that but there
seems to be this expectation from a lot
of people that have been coming by where
they want to get shown around spend a
couple hours just hanging out if we did
that every day with all the people that
would want to come by we wouldn't get
anything done and then no one would want
to come by so it's a bit of a catch-22
for us too because would you want a
random person to just find your address
online or find Sam's phone number and
call him and show up just stay up on
what we're doing we have opportunities
where we're at conventions where we
throw different events where you can
meet us and you can meet and greet with
us if you want us to see your work send
us your work contact that corridor -
digital comm send us your real awesome
I'd love to check it out Thank You Nico
and Sam came into this building in 2008
and we've been working out of it since
2009 over the course of those beautiful
seven years we've made all these
improvements and it all has culminated
in this studio tour right here right now
Jake made us canacee finally
we got the 3-ton air conditioner three
tons of super-awesome we repaint it I
gotta tell ya I think it looks great
oh and you may have noticed something
else if you look up there's no horrible
horrific cancerous air conditioner
anymore
this air conditioner that they had up
there that he couldn't even keep it
running because the chemicals that he
would had to use to keep it running are
now illegal in the state of California
we got rid of that and then we insulated
and sheetrock the whole ceiling so it
looks real nice and it keeps the cool
air in Nicko's aunty was caring and kind
and nice enough to donate couple
paintings from one of her warehouses and
we've taken the time to hang them up on
the walls to give a little bit of color
spark apparently red engages the mind
that's why it's in some of the work area
what does yellow mean I just like those
colors come on let's show them the new
the new work areas this used to be where
my desk was and now it is officially the
Sam and Nico corner what do you have to
say about that Nick
I like quarters Nico's desk but he no
longer uses because he's dissatisfied
with his Windows 10 update and thanks to
the 2d printer the corner for idiots
right here back here under the stairs
we've got the new 3d printer
courtesy of formlabs Sam keeps it tucked
in at night
let's keep it under this blankie have
you ever wondered how Sam will be as a
father
turn it on for 15 hours and walk away
come on over here
here is the quiet lounge there's a
couple of different functions that this
room serves number one it's an audio
proofed room relatively so we do a lot
of our sound recording and sound design
in here Ren comes in to take maps or
just to cat around scratch on the
furniture we also have meetings in here
and also as of late Sam and Nico have
been using it for a little riders
meaning that
every day we demonstrate the audio
isolation no reverb so you can record in
here it sounds great here we have the
most important corner I really like it
back here it's quiet
I'm also my computer faces the wall so
I'm not distracted when you guys are
running around shooting things this is
the effects / additional editing area
Ren's
lab is over here the render station Jake
come on close it okay sorry render
station it is Ren's little research
development / crazy science lab and over
here we've got a really really nice 4k
monitor thanks to LG here we have our
Awards wall my favorite things on here
are as follows and in this order the
Johnny Boz award the picture of Sam
defending the nation and our hearts the
patreon golden thousand and our streamys
here's my crisis zone cabinet that
bought for $250 from my neighbor this is
one of those old cars that someone keeps
in their garage where they go all you
need is a radiator and it'll work fine
but it's been sitting here for so long
that no one really knows what's wrong
it's exactly what it is this is our
giant loading door I painted it gray
because it gives depth to the loading
area this is where I keep all our stuff
that we shoot videos with let's just say
that we haven't been that is cold bows
and arrows for shooting at each other
this is a minecraft hallway do I need to
say anything else I love this this
pickaxe is signed by notch himself
before he was famous I'm gonna workshop
anytime we need to make a prop costume
tinker with something this is where we
are and here we have the young wall
thank you Rhett Reynolds for painting
and organizing this people R&B like
plenty of flowers and you're gonna Bowl
flowers aren't a weapon these are fire
flowers they are the most dangerous
thing on this wall you guys remember
when the game called overwatch came out
and there's another game that looked the
same called battle born well this is a
robot from battle born his name is Beorn
cuz we're keep our expiry parts this is
the prop room we keep everything that is
generally a prop in here somewhere as
shown the sink this thing's cool the man
who lived here before us did a lot
milling in our
and you did this thing where you took a
bunch pieces of plywood and laminated
them all together and then milled down a
sink out of it so you have a pretty
cool-looking sink this is our affects
corner basically anything that has to do
with special effects you put back here
you may remember from the vlogs about
five months ago I had a couple guys come
in here where you do all the shelving
after we renovated we repainted it all
we brought everything back up here and
now BAM
this is the kitchen we haven't done a
hole up here but we did repaint it's
clean I really like the twin Pete style
floor in the kitchen a little dream of
dudes making videos turn into still a
bunch of dudes making videos everything
in this studio that you see camera gear
props equipment computers used to fit on
two desks and two shelves the reason
there's more than that now is because of
you guys because you guys watching us
you guys supporting us patrons people
buying merch you guys are the reason we
have all this so we're gonna keep trying
to make good stuff using all this you
guys get rewarded I will never be upset
at a fan I will never be mad at somebody
for coming up and saying they like my
stuff they want to picture with me but
that said doesn't mean I can't hide away
my little studio and right alone I'm
actually good stuff done we're just
really busy this is literally what it
comes down to I don't care personally I
don't care I think it's fantastic
but I can't take three hours out of
every day to give someone a studio
anyway I'm not even I'm not going to do
it
cheese update and Jesus Oh problem wrong
[Music]